some big news mgm resorts will be
resuming operations 24 7
at mandalay bay park mgm and the mirage
come march 3. the change comes as the
company sees increased interest to
travel here to our area
8 news now reporter sally jade emile is
live outside the mandalay bay with what
this means for those visiting great news
sally
kirsten it's another step in
revitalizing our economy and the people
i spoke to today say they are extremely
happy
excited they can't wait so you might
remember previously each property had
implemented selective midweek closures
due to the decrease
in business as mgm resorts begins to see
what they called
positive signs with people traveling
getting a vaccine and cold
numbers going down the decision was made
to be back to a full week operations
all with safety protocols taking place
bernard carter is visiting from detroit
he says he feels safe and is looking
forward to exploring more once things
are fully open
i think that will be something good to
pick back up businesses
in the area and i would be interested in
staying there
the next time i come
the company is also announcing that
several of its live entertainment shows
will return to the stage this month
and early march now mgm resorts is also
very optimistic about las vegas recovery
and their ability to bring those workers
back to work they are excited for that
reporting live sally jaramillo
8 news now